[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno yo soy manuel laredo como les dije
hace un momento tengo 36 años soy
cochabambino
y como muchos de ustedes provengo de una
familia numerosa mi papá tiene siete
hermanos mi mamá tiene trece hermanos y
eso quiere significar que las cosas eran
muy importantes para ellos la idea de
usar y botar algo no entraba dentro de
su cabeza
todavía me acuerdo como mi papá me
contaba cómo hacía carritos con las
latas de atún o mi mamá que tenía que
cuidar su ropa para que le pueda pasar a
su próximo hermano lo que pasa es que
para ellos todo tenía un valor inclusive
para mí que mis primeras ropas fueron
hechas los retazos de los ternos de mi
abuelo que fueron confeccionados por mi
abuela pero eso ha cambiado
actualmente nosotros estamos sacando más
recursos de lo que el planeta puede
generar qué quiere decir eso que
nosotros estamos exprimiendo el planeta
más o menos para mantener el estilo de
vida que tenemos actualmente
necesitamos dos planetas tierras y uno
puede pensar de que esto solamente es no
sé para eeuu que tienen un modelo de
vida que necesita cinco veces o china
que tienen un modelo de vida que tiene
tres o alemania- pero quiero decirles
algo el 19 de julio del 2018 aquí en
bolivia ha sido el día del sobrecargo
del planeta eso ha pasado
aproximadamente dos semanas antes del
promedio general del mundo
y es que este es un problema real del
que estamos viviendo
[Música]
al mismo tiempo que nosotros estamos
sacando una cantidad increíble de
recursos del planeta estamos generando
una cantidad increíble de residuos que
luego van a parar a los ríos a los mares
a la calle y si tenemos suerte a los
botaderos como este botadero que es el
botadero de k'ara k'ara en cochabamba
que es uno de los 5 botaderos más
peligrosos del mundo
y eso se debe a que nosotros tenemos un
estilo de vida desechable hemos
priorizado la generación de riqueza en
función de lo que podemos hacer con
nuestro planeta dependemos de una
economía lineal pero qué es una economía
lineal es cuando nosotros sacamos
recursos producimos usamos y votamos
sacamos recursos producimos usamos y
votamos y la pregunta que yo me hago es
porque necesitamos tener una bolsa de
plástico que se fabrica en
aproximadamente 10 segundos se utiliza
media hora de llevar nuestras cosas del
supermercado del mercado a nuestra casa
y luego tardan 400 años en degradarse
o porque tenemos que comprar el último
celular de moda no es verdad
siendo que el celular que tenemos
actualmente todavía funciona
a eso ustedes tienen que sumarle de que
cada 30 años se duplica la cantidad de
personas en nuestro planeta y eso quiere
decir que en el 2040 nuestros hijos ya
tendrán problemas de abastecimiento de
agua o como dice stephen hawkings
prácticamente dentro de mil años la
humanidad ya no existirán
[Música]
por eso nosotros necesitamos un cambio
sistémico
qué quiere decir eso un cambio en el que
pensemos en generar riqueza
preservando el bienestar de las
generaciones futuras y cómo se puede
hacer esto pensando de manera circular
pensar de manera circular permite
generar una economía que está pensada en
sacar los recursos utilizarlos el mayor
tiempo posible dentro de la economía y
después de eso
e intentar generar la menor cantidad de
residuos
suena bastante interesante pero como
nosotros podemos participar en eso la
primera a través del consumo responsable
si cuando nosotros compramos productos
verdes o compramos productos que pueden
ser utilizados nosotros estamos apoyando
la economía circular si al final detener
ese consumo responsable igual generamos
residuos podemos separar esos recursos
esos residuos y convertirlos en recursos
que pueden ser utilizados por empresas
y una de las partes importantes es que
con la economía circular se puede
redefinir y se puede repensar todo el
modelo de desarrollo a través de
soluciones innovadoras que hagan un
cambio y que resuelvan los problemas
reales de nuestra sociedad
el 80% de la basura es reciclable
pero yo escucho en cochabamba no se
puede reciclar
no sé qué me dicen al final igual lo van
a mezclar dentro del basurero y si es
verdad pasa eso pero lo que pasa es que
nosotros no estamos siendo capaces de
ver sistemas no tradicionales que
funcionan dentro de la necesidad y eso
es bastante importante porque la
oportunidad de viajar me ha permitido
tener una una forma de ver cosas que no
están pasando
y eso es lo que estaba pasando en
cochabamba la basura que nosotros
separamos de nuestros residuos son
recogidos por unas personas por unos
héroes que se llaman los eco
recolectores y esas personas separan la
basura y le entregan a empresas
cochabambinas que están generando
productos del reciclado de la llanta
no sé si ustedes sabían pero las
botellas de plástico ahora tienen 30 por
ciento de reciclado de pet
no sé si ustedes sabían pero el papel
higiénico que ustedes utilizan es
fabricado en bolivia y se fabrica de
papel reciclado de nuestra ciudad y
también es importante saber de que somos
una de las pocas ciudades que tiene una
planta que recicla el vidrio en
cochabamba hay más de 200 empresas que
trabajan así generando trabajo para
2.000 personas directas y generando
trabajos por más de 10.000 personas
indirectamente es una economía que mueve
aproximadamente 100 millones de dólares
cada año
el 2013
junto con mi hermano y ronald gonzález
formamos una empresa de reciclado en la
cocina de mi mamá
la idea era convertir esos 30 millones
de llantas que existen votadas en el
país en algún producto que mejore la
calidad de vida de la gente es así que
con tecnología transformamos los
residuos de la llanta y los
transformamos en pisos han muerto y
guantes de goma
una de las cosas que nos dijeron al
principio que intentábamos demandar
capital para este proyecto íbamos a los
bancos presentábamos el proyecto y ellos
nos preguntaban al final de la charla a
ver un ratito no estoy entendiendo es
decir quieren hacer una empresa de
basura y si de basura no y saben por qué
porque el oficial de crédito el que
tiene que dar los créditos para el
desarrollo no es capaz de pensar de
forma circular no puede creer de que
pueda haber una forma de trabajar en
forma de los residuos es verdad y otra
cosa que nos pasó que fue bastante
interesante no sé si ustedes saben pero
en cochabamba y en bolivia no hay una
recicladora de llanta estos me
preguntaban cómo van a hacer pisos de
reciclado de latas si no hay recicladora
de llanta es inviable
sí si piensas de forma tradicional
bolivia tiene una característica
interesante hacemos las cosas diferentes
y tenemos que tener la capacidad de ver
cómo hacemos estas cosas diferentes en
bolivia hace años que ya reciclan
llantas a barcas sogas no los
recaudadores le dan una nueva vida a las
llantas y nosotros hemos entrado dentro
de esa economía circular a comprarles
establecido picamos y con tecnología
hacemos parques infantiles y gimnasios
esto nos ha permitido hacer proyectos en
20 ciudades en bolivia y actualmente en
3 países de la región yo vivo de la
economía circular
pero
aunque no crean existe un montón de
jóvenes que están teniendo la capacidad
de dejar de pensar linealmente y
comenzar a ver sistemas no tradicionales
actualmente en cochabamba ya hay alguien
que distribuye a través de bicicletas
eléctricas o hay alguien que se ha dado
cuenta de que usar el agua puede ser un
negocio inclusive
se han dado cuenta de que nuestros
residuos cuando morimos pueden
transformarse a través de macetas
degradables en árboles que luego puedes
tu trapear mediante gps
ella es maya tiene 3 años es mi hija
desde que somos chiquitos buenos de que
es chiquita ella junto con mi esposa le
enseñamos que la basura va al basurero
la anterior vez estábamos saliendo de un
concierto llegamos al estadio y salimos
y era una marea una marea de plásticos
así como los que vemos en internet o en
facebook entonces mi hijita comenzó a
levantar la basura al principio tenemos
la decisión de decirle no no no lo hagas
no pero como le puedes decir una persona
que actúe diferente de lo que tú le
dices todos los días así que con mi
esposa buscamos una bolsa
esperamos que la persona que mi hija
guarde toda la basura que podía se cansó
por suerte y después de eso agarramos la
bolsa y nos la llevamos a nuestra casa
en el camino nos ponemos a pensar que al
final igual dejamos una marea increíble
de basura
y es que el tema no va solamente de
enseñar a las personas que la basura va
al basurero sino va enseñarles mediante
acciones de que el futuro de nuestro
planeta depende de un cambio en el
estilo de vida y yo les digo esto porque
creo que cambiar es posible muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]